I have a website selling luxury sex toys
and design a bedroom accessory yep
like okay calm if anyone wants anything
um it's a really nice privacy is bad
really nice mark and I was interested in
what you were saying earlier about going
round the sort of I have be pretty big
competitors you can throw a lot of money
at stuff in the up discount and I'm
trying to operate in a more luxury
without being you know yes too niche
what advice would you give someone hon
tent content is the game you have to
like that wait yeah yes like listen this
is what she sells she's got no problem
what's your problem I'm shy I'm saving
myself yeah I get it
wait what I just go to that to put
something in I don't worry I think that
you need to really you know to me it's
about content so you you think of
something iconic like playboy right it
wasn't just the pictures there was other
things that fed to the demo I would do
really if we were working together I'd
actually look at who's actually buying
the product because I'll focus website
and still 60% of the people who buy from
me and then yep and it's how to really
harness harness that market for me
because rather than fighting to harness
another market that won't come to me
citizen I think I think that there's a
lot of tasteful ways for you to be very
successful in using things I mean I
would tell you that Pinterest
infographics for you for the female 40%
is a complete no-brainer I would tell
you that you've got to do a lot more
blogging than [ __ ] listen to give an
answer that will benefit everybody every
single person in this room and every one
of your businesses slash organizations
your teacher whatever you do every one
of them you and the business you are in
the media business you're not in the sex
toy business you're in the media
business comma sex toy business got it
media business comma DJ shy sex toy guy
right
so so the second everybody in this room
the Michelin tire company the Michelin
tire company one hundred years ago had a
business problem people weren't driving
enough yet to wear out their tires and
thus they didn't buy tires do you know
what they did they started the Michelin
review the reason there's three star
Michelin as my friends is because a tire
company needed people to drive and so
they went out to the countryside and
started reviewing the best restaurants
and all these things and made it up
because they probably wanted to say the
best foie gras was the furthest place
out then they took the books put it in
London in Paris and got people to dress
if somebody would pick up a book at the
fancy you know place it'd be like oh the
best foie gras is in Burgundy honey
we're going to Burgundy this weekend and
started drunk they literally fix their
business problem of using tires by
getting people to go far away by using
media one of the things you could be
talking about you should be talking
about cigars and golf and what you call
football and I call soccer you can be
blogging about this and you should be
looking at things like BuzzFeed who make
content that's viral right you should
have a blog post putting like the seven
best balls you know right and so like
there's a lot of plays that you can have
but you need to become a media company
the only way you're gonna be able to
beat competitors that can throw money
against search which I'm sure is a huge
driver for your industry the only way
you're gonna be able to compete with
that
is to become the authority of content
it's why I started Wine Library TV right
I became the Wine Spectator Jancis
Robinson Robert Parker right you need to
do that but you don't have to just do it
as direct as I did with Wine Library TV
we're pitching a client right now that
sells crackers to become the leading
reviewer of cheese right and and so like
you can play with things that are within
the world of the thing that you actually
sell yeah for sure but you have to do it
right like like it's like exercise right
like this book and what I just told you
is right right but so is the way to get
a six pack in your stomach right there's
a right way to get a six pack for your
stomach
there's exercises right
and there's a diet I know what they are
I'm not doing it so so I I can tell you
what to do I can write for $30 you can
find out what to do but the problem is
back to that other question where I got
kind of like in my zone its execution
you know what the answers are maybe you
don't there's plenty of people that look
like myself that can give you a lot of
good ones but you have to pick them and
actually do them period London we got
another question back
[Applause]